do you think um
the OC will ever have a movie
a movie yeah because they're doing
movies with all these shows I feel like
it could be like a limited
I'm gonna throw that out there
yeah of course like oh see like Josh
Schwartz is my family like yeah he cast
you in another thing a couple things
yeah but we're also like he's one of my
best friends he's like my brother yeah
we're so close I would and Stephanie
Savage as well like I always say I would
do anything they would just be like you
want to do this it doesn't matter what
it is it'd be like okay yeah when do I
wear where do I go
um but my pitch is a limited series
let's do eight maybe ten probably eight
episodes
and call today would everybody come back
you think I'm trying to we're trying to
like break some people down to see oh so
you're already in on this no I mean no
you are none we have we have a few hard
no's so it's not gonna happen probably
but you won't even tell me the hard no's
but yeah I mean if you Google it I'm
sure the hard nose were there to be
right the hard nose are there